j'accueille maintenant steeve estatof
vous connaissez non non c'est toi qui tu
connais style oui la nouvelle star
laurent je les ai vus dans ton émission
oui je les vendais signalions vous le
connaissez dit ressemblent à polnareff à
ses débuts j'espère qu'il finira mieux
aujourd'hui à la fin plus revu souhaite
un le 13 mai dernier vous avez été donc
sacrée nouvelle star sur m6 devant plus
de 4 millions de fidèles steve et c'est
un événement parce que c'était la
première fois que ce type d'émission
était gagné par quelqu'un qui était
visant au rock attitude et qui n'était
pas fan de céline dion michel berger
comme ça et ça a été une sorte
d'événement
ben pour moi en tout cas c'est un
événement si sûr mais pour ce genre
d'émission aussi un seul aura fait
beaucoup de bien parce qu'on s'est
aperçu qu'avec des mecs qui se l'est
joué ça dans ce genre d'émission
alors aujourd'hui vous sortez un premier
album qui s'appelle à l'envers et un
premier single qui s'appelle 1977
est ce que vous connaissez orlando ouais
monsieur l'esquivé orlando orlando exige
le pli bravo ouais